hey there today I'm going to do
something a little bit old-school and
I'm going to be reviewing an exam from
1866 so this is an arithmetic exam and
it's from 152 years ago if my arithmetic
is any good now this is called the
Regents questions and I believe it's
from an exam from the state of New York
the Regents exams that are designed for
I think graduating high school students
to be able to graduate and get their
diploma so to be able to prove you know
everything that you've sort of learned
during your courses there
I believe the Regents exams still sort
of exists today in some form but it's
not the same as it was back then this is
an arithmetic exam and I think it's
since been replaced by things like
geometry algebra calculus and many other
different disciplines so regardless of
what form the Regents exams look like
these days we're going to have a look
through these are very old questions and
just see what life was like back then
for a budding mathematician I'm going to
go out on a hunch and assume that there
are no calculators involved here so
you're going to have to be doing all
this by hand and it kind of makes sense
but they want to train you up to be good
at arithmetic to be good at things like
bookkeeping or just general day-to-day
sums now I got these questions from a
book which was published in 1880 it's
publicly available online and I'll link
to it and it's just a database of all
these past problems going all the way
back to the start so follow along with
that if you would like to and in my next
video which will be uploaded shortly
after this one I will actually work
through in detail one of the more tricky
questions from this exam because in this
video we're not going to really work
them out just have a look at what
they're like so let's get started so
here is page 1 we have the regents
questions arithmetic examination 1
November 8th 1866 let's go through the
problems number 1 right and figures each
of the following numbers add them and
express it in words their sum so we've
got some numbers written down in words
it's would seem kind of easy to just
write them down in digits but this is in
1866 exam after all so it's a little bit
trickier than that they've given us
56,000 and 14 thousandths so I guess
they're talking about the places after
the decimal point here so you would have
liked your tenths hundredths thousandths
and tens of thousands digits so the
numbers are a little bit trickier we've
got 19 and 1957 and 48 10 thousandths
23,000 five and four tenths and 14
millions so a little bit trickier but I
think it's still all right number two
what is the difference between three and
eight quarters plus seven and five
eighths and four plus two and eight
quarters so this is a fractions problem
we've got some mixed fractions here I
think the rule is just going to be you
need to add some fractions essentially
and to do that you'll need to I guess
convert them to have a common
denominator so getting out of mixed
fractions into improper ones question
three and multiplying by more than one
figure where is the first figure in each
partial product written and why is it so
written now this one seems a little bit
confusing I don't really know what
they're saying as far as I can tell
they're talking about multiplying by
more than one figure and to me that
means when you have say two numbers
being multiplied together and each
number is like more than one of the
jitan size and you do that thing when
you do it colored by column so you'd go
2 by 8 16 carry the 1 1 by 8 plus that 9
and then you do like the next one the 10
so that would be 4 and that would be 2
and then you add these up that would be
3 3 6 so I think that's what they're
talking about but I guess I don't really
know
so the question whereas each partial
product written that is the partial
products are they talking about carrying
the one or something like that number
four if the divisor is 19 the quotient
37 and the remainder 11 what is the
dividend so the dividend is the number
to be divided by something so the
dividend is divided by 19 the answer of
37 with a remainder of 11 so to work
backwards and find what the dividend is
we do 19 times 37 plus 11 number five
what is the quotient of 65 eu1 PK and
3qt divided by 12 so these are a bunch
of I guess units that I'm not familiar
with I did a quick google of them and I
think it's caught pig and bushel but
yeah I guess I don't really know how
many of each of these is and this one
and likewise but you'd have to convert
them down to I guess the court divided
by 12 and then maybe convert it back
into these types of units again number
six which of the fundamental operations
or ground rules of arithmetic is
employed in reduction descending so
initially I had no idea what reduction
listening is but I gave this one a quick
google as well and I think it refers to
when you're like going down and
denomination like so if you have dollars
and you want to convert it into since if
I had a dollar and I want to tell how
many cents wasn't it I would times it by
a hundred so I believe this one would be
multiplication number seven in
exchanging gold dust for cotton by what
weight would each be weighed this one
seems a bit out of my range I guess I
don't know exactly what they're saying
but I feel like maybe they're on some
old-school scale and they're like
needing to weigh gold dust and cotton
against some standard weight I'm not
really sure here's one that I think
we'll be able to get what is the only
even prime number
that would to number nine how many weeks
and this many minutes about eight
million I think this would be a process
of dividing and probably a series of
long division problems so you'd want to
convert from minutes divide it by 60 to
find out how many hours there are
divided by 24 to get how many days
divided by seven days into weeks so a
series of division hope you'll sharpen
up your long division skills because
mine are very rusty number ten to what
term and division does the value of a
common fraction correspond I don't
really know what the terms and division
are except that it could be like the
dividend the divisor the quotient or the
remainder or something I'm gonna have to
pass on that one though number eleven
what is the product of a fraction
multiplied by its denominator well if we
had the fraction one-half and multiplied
it by two you just end up with one or
you just end up with whatever you
started with on the top so that would be
ending up with the numerator number
twelve what is the rule for the
multiplication of decimals now this one
hasn't been outdated this rule still
applies the rule is that the decimal
point is placed in the product so that
the number of decimal places in the
product is the sum of decimal places and
what you're multiplying together so for
example if you're multiplying a number
with two decimal places by a number with
one decimal place your answer will have
to have three decimal places in it
that's still something that I remember
doing in school number thirteen how is a
common fraction reduced to a decimal I
gets to convert a fraction to a decimal
what you're doing is you're dividing the
numerator by the denominator so I guess
that's all you can do maybe do it by
long division number fourteen what is
ratio and how may it be expressed this
one's a little difficult to put into
words but I guess I would say that a
ratio is in
of times one value is like contained
within the other 15 if this amount of
coal costs the cement dollars
what will this amount of coal costs I
think this is another case of like
converting this whole value into like
the lowest denominator so like pounds is
that I don't know and then working out
how much each pound costs think you
moving this one into pounds - and
working out its total cost number 16
find the cost of the several articles
and the amount of the following bill
this one is a little bit awkward I think
it got something to do with the rent or
something so we've got a peed unit -
paying - dr. Samuel Palmer for some
amount feet of or debt some amount per M
so I guess this is literally square feet
of space or that you're aborting and
this is either the cost per meter like
square meter per month I'm not sure I
guess in essence you'd have to
understand the language here and what's
common in terms of these types of things
but it probably comes down to just
adding up these different articles 17
what is the length of the side of a
cubical box which contains three hundred
and eighty nine thousand and seventeen
solid inches excuse me that this one
seems pretty difficult to do without a
calculator like so much more than the
other ones I guess doing a cube root
without a calculator is not something
that I am well-versed in but you would
have to do it through either like long
division and type sums or through is
some sort of estimation and checking
method number eighteen what is the
present worth of the following note
discounted at a bank and when will it
become due so we've got a nice little
letter here ninety days from date for
value received I promised a paid to the
order of John Smith one hundred dollars
the old New City National Bank of John
Brown forgive me if I'm mistaken this
one seems to just be asking how much
it's worth and it seems to be a hundred
dollars paid 90 days from the date this
is the date here so maybe this is some
basic bookkeeping type skills although I
would say these types of word problems
kind of do age this exam a little you
really wouldn't see something written in
the same way today something that has
not aged itself though in fact has aged
pretty well is things like this where
it's just using the numbers and the most
basic sentences maybe this one here
involve 5/8 to the seventh power that's
pretty much the same as what you'd see
today except maybe the word involved
would be changed to find 5/8 or like so
five minutes something like that
for this question though it seems easy
in essence you just need to take 5/8
times it by itself
seven times although when you do do it
it turns out to get a little bit
difficult on the algebra for example I
worked out what five eighths to the
sixth power would be so this would
represent what you're going to have to
do in your final sum to get the seventh
out but to the sixth power you're
already dealing with fraction 1 5 6 to 5
over 2 6 2 1 4 4 so already you're
getting quite high and you still need to
take this and times it again by 5 over
so I don't think that's necessarily like
a walk in the park because even though
you know what to do you do have to
actually go into the details every time
and it would be a little bit of time to
solve it number 20 what is the square
root of zero point zero zero four three
zero four six seven two one now this
question has me a little bit shook
because just like the cube root question
on the previous page the seems sort of
absurd to be asking I think without the
calculator but actually I guess it can
be done and it's interesting to me to
actually learn more about how
I've done this so in the next video
which I'm going to upload shortly after
this one I'll take this problem here and
we'll see if we can solve it by hand
maybe we'll have a little bit of fun
there but I'm really interested to
actually work through how you would do
that without the luxury of the
calculator maybe I'm too used to the
luxury number 21 we have an amount of
sugar or a dozen price it looks like
it's like lost 12% in price so how much
was the whole cost for something like
this I guess in essence it's the same as
what we still do these days if you want
to find out how much it was worth before
it depreciated you would take the total
amount now divide it by 0.88 and that
would tell you how much it was worth to
start with number 22 a person owned five
eighths of a mine and sold eight
quarters of his interest for this amount
what was the value of the entire mine I
feel like this would have made sense to
me if he was selling some sensible
portion of his share of the mine but it
seems like he's selling well too of his
share so I don't know how you can
actually sell more than what you have
that sort of seems like to me I guess
this must be like a multiplication as a
fraction somewhere but the wording is so
awkward I'd probably be a little bit
tricked yeah nearly at the end number 23
it's talking about at a certain time at
a certain longitude use that to work out
what time it will be at a different
longitude this one actually seems
interesting to me because I guess we
take for granted like time zones and
longitude and I guess the relationship
between but if you really do think about
it every hour of time zone difference
would actually correspond to a change of
15 degrees in the longitude so I guess
you can use that effect to work out here
how the time is changing and finally
another question using several different
units here which are not major questions
I mean that's why it's hard to start
with
I guess converting it down into some
unit that you choose and then dividing
this price by their number I don't know
what potage is but okay I guess I roll
the Signet exam spooks me a little
because I I've gone through a lot of
mathematics but this this paper is not
really about mathematics observe this
everything it's what it says it's really
testing your long division your a
multiplication your basic skills like
that which can actually fall out of
practice the further you go into maths
it's sort of funny to talk with my
friends about how bad we are sometimes
at arithmetic considering our
qualifications and some of these really
high level ideas you know if we you let
go out to dinner together it will take
several of us to just work out how to
split the bill it's not like these are
the skills that you actually really
practice every day and the further you
go it gets more and more abstract from
PS but it makes sense this was 1866 and
I guess even when I was in high school
our teachers and the hindsight's sort of
lied to us and said you've got to learn
these skills because you're not going to
just have a calculator in your pocket
everywhere you go I turns out that's
turned out to be sort of true but it's
perm our smartphones and everything but
back in 1866 I guess that sentiment
actually did ring true that you didn't
have a calculator in your pocket I guess
it raises the question of nowadays is
arithmetic important like eventually
some of these skills have been phased
out even in the Regents exam since this
first one and it's kind of my opinion
that arithmetic is less and less
important to learn and to know and to
have so much practice in because whilst
I think it's still valuable to know the
of what you're doing and and to call
yourself a mathematician without
understanding how to do long division
it's a little bit strange I admit but
also there's so much to learn and so
much to do that really we only have time
to focus on doing the important things
that are new but in having said that
probably around the world there are
still some exams like this some
countries I think would focus more on
making sure that someone who wants to
call themselves a mathematician can do
these like square roots by hand I never
had to prove that but I'm sure somewhere
in the world this is still the kind of
thing you're having to prove and I guess
I'm not the judge of whether that's good
or bad or not but respect to the people
that could solve all of this exam no
worries because it's already what
they've been practicing I'd like to
thank brilliant org for sponsoring
today's video on brilliant model you can
sharpen your own competitiveness when
taking exams hopefully a little bit
different from the exam we looked at
today but I'm brilliant they do have
courses covering mathematical
fundamentals as well as some competitive
exams such as the AMC they have a course
on how to ace the AMC and they cover all
sorts of ideas around that including
exam techniques and how to best
eliminate multiple-choice questions if
you're interested to learn more about
this then you can go to brilliant org
slash
tibbie's and sign up for free also the
first 200 people who follow that link
can get 20% off an annual premium
subscription thanks to brilliant and I
would recommend them as a place where
you can take quizzes and really test
your knowledge rather than just sort of
passively trying to learn
about ideas the interactive nature of
the site makes it a really good learning
resource